make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and before we get into this video
for the twitch stream the comics
explained twitch stream where we
basically just stream the videos 24 7.
we've got a schedule now and so if you
go to twitch.tv comics explained
you'll see a schedule down there but you
can also type exclamation mark
schedule and that will pull up what the
schedule is right so it'll tell you what
that week's video is we're also going to
do a live q and a session
every friday at 6 30 p.m and then a
watch party at 7 30 p.m right like
watching comic book movies and different
things like that together you do need
amazon prime to be able to do it but
yeah so it's it's cool right so
twitch.tv
commerce explained it's a cool concept i
like it i think it's pretty awesome i
love i love talking to you guys right
like i was in there for like seven hours
yesterday and we made up like a comic
book video game it's basically skyrim
meets marvel comics it's amazing
but yeah so um this three joker story
is ridiculously good right like it's
it's crazy how good it is and here's the
thing a little bit of history here for
those of you guys who are kind of coming
into this and you're like okay i don't
remember everything that's going on
so this really comes out of the events
of what was
basically dark side war right like kind
of like this revelation when batman was
on the mobius chair which was the chair
that granted him absolute knowledge and
he asked the question who's the joker
and we were told there's three of them
and what we were basically given here
was
what was essentially the original joker
right so the old like bob kane
bill finger joker then we have the
killing joke joker and then we have the
silver age joker right so we've got like
three of them running around three
jokers from three different eras and at
this point we're just now learning what
all this is about right like three or
four years after it was all kind of
teased but what this does is it
basically picks up with batman right
inside the bad cave basically receiving
treatment for you know having been out
for you know fighting crime that night
really kind of the run-of-the-mill stuff
the cool thing about this right this
this art is done by jason fabach he's
probably one of the greatest artists in
the entirety of comic book artistry and
of course written by jeff johns but you
have this thing where like like batman's
basically being tended to by alfred and
we get these
these scars of batman right like the
scar on his back where bane broke his
back
a scar where he was basically burned by
the riddler where he was scratched by
catwoman where he was bit by killer croc
he was stabbed by the scarecrow he was
shot by joker just like
all these different scars but the cool
thing about this is we're given like
these different injuries at the hands of
various jokers over the years right the
three different jokers right where he
was sprayed with like it with the the
acid lapel where he was cut with a
playing card like it's kind of cool
right because we get this little bit of
a flashback to like the early days of
batman the very early days of bruce
right where you have bruce and his
family
walking out of the mask of zorro movie
bruce is excited about he's like yeah
man it's like the coolest thing ever and
then they end up down at dark alley
because his dad wanted to take a
shortcut and his parents were shot by
joe chill this is a little bit of an
origin for bruce now this is kind of
if i had to be honest it's kind of jeff
jones just being like let's get to the
humanity of all of this but like let's
break bruce down to his most base form
right who is bruce
he's a sad little kid crying because his
mom and his daddy got shot right that's
one of the best lines from like the bat
what was it batman begins but like where
where bruce wayne like after his parents
are killed he goes to like tom wilkinson
who's in like that bar
that really cd bar you know and he's
like he's like there's a congressman
there's a judge and so on and so forth
and he's like he's like you think
because your mommy and your daddy got
shot that you understand what this life
is like like you've never tasted
desperate right like you're the you're
you're bruce wayne you're the prince of
gotham you have to drive a thousand
miles to find someone who doesn't know
your name
like i love that line right because it
perfectly encapsulates bruce wayne right
he's just a little rich kid whose mommy
and daddy got shot and now he
understands the criminal underworld like
it's it's cool because in the early days
that was not the case now
in the midst of all this we're they're
suddenly met by the arrival of a
broadcast it says that like the moxen
crime family were all
executed at a restaurant essentially and
the execution was done at the hands of
the joker the next thing that really
goes on here is that we switch over to
batgirl and while batgirl is exercising
we end up getting this this
news footage of a comedian who was
executed by the joker and it's kind of
cool because
for for her she basically hits this idea
of of her having been shot by the joker
during killing joke which the reason why
this joker is kind of considered
separate from the other ones is because
originally killing joke was not part of
the dc continuity right it was a story
that was just out there by itself
somewhere but it was
wildly popular when it came out right
when it was released and even now it's
still considered to be the definitive
origin of the joker but the idea is that
barbara gordon kind of relives a time
when she was shot by by the joker just
to basically torture her and to show her
tortured images to jim gordon to prove
that he could make jim gordon go insane
but the next thing it does is it
switches over to something that i
totally did not expect it switches to
the red hood right it switches over to
jason
todd and you have jason todd here who's
basically facing off against some
henchmen right just beating the crap out
of these guys
all the while reliving these memories
when the joker beat him to death right
when the joker basically killed him now
again as most of you guys probably know
this was in response to the fact that dc
fans didn't like
jason todd right that when dick grayson
was brought onto the scene in in the old
detective comic stories and he was the
first robin and the sidekick of batman
for you know something like 30 years or
something like that when
dc finally rolled him over and made him
nightwing when he was basically aged up
they wanted to keep the element of robin
right so they brought in jason todd the
problem was that jason todd's origin
story was like identical to dick
grayson's and fans didn't like it
because they thought that
it was dc just kind of throwing away the
story of dick for the purpose of just
like creating another version of his
character and so what this did is it led
to dc
killing jason todd but the red hood is
here because he's basically
interrogating the guys or the joker
right he's interrogating his henchmen
and is like
telling me what it like tell me where
the joker is but the next thing we do is
we pick up with this major
this kind of death of these individuals
at the ace chemical factory and you've
got like jim gordon and you've got
harvey bullock and you've got these guys
responding and kind of looking over this
whole scene batman of course
ends up showing up here and the reason
why is because what what's what's
happened
is that over the course of a single
night all three jokers
struck right the moxen crime family the
ace chemical factory being robbed and
the comedian being killed this all
happened in one night and that's where
like harvey bullock and jim gordon and
them were like okay this doesn't make
any sense right there's no way the joker
could have could have taken out could
have done all three of these things he'd
have to be in three places at once
the only way it's true is if there's
three of the jokers running around and
notice this the immediate answer here is
okay well if there is more than one
joker then you have one joker and two
impostors that's the knee-jerk throwaway
reaction but you basically end up having
batman essentially talking to somebody
and of course the cops think he's more
or less lost his mind only for us to
find out he's talking to batgirl and
that this ace chemical this this that
basically is the one that joker
originally fell into back in like batman
number one or really kind of not really
batman number one definitively but the
original joker fell
into this vat of edits chemicals and
became the joker right so it has
significance it has meaning only for us
to find out that one of these guys
is basically still alive right one of
these individuals who was kind of
dousing the chemicals and so on is still
alive
the other part of this is that we end up
finding out that when it came to these
three particular crimes the joker wanted
people to know he did them
it's why like when he was walking
through this ace chemical factory he
looked at every single security camera
that was working it's why he live
streamed one of the murders in every
single one of these cases
he wanted people to know he was there so
people would kind of look and it would
basic literally draw them
you know drive them crazy and say like
what in the world is going on here now
for these three bodies that were here
these are just
you know just a distraction it's
designed to keep the cops focusing on
them as opposed to focusing on the tire
tracks
of course batman picks up on that but
with this one guy being alive he's
thrown into an ambulance and basically
begun
you know they started the purpose of
getting him to the to the hospital only
for us to find out that
inside the ambulance is jason todd right
is the red hood who immediately grabs
this guy and like starts getting to work
on him and is like tell me everything
you know now here's the cool thing this
is what i love so much about this right
i firmly believe that in dc comics right
now
no one can write batman characters the
way that that jeff
johns can scott snyder is really good at
like world building right he's good at
like building a mythos i think jeff
jones is you know a little better than
that proven by by the nature of like the
green lantern mythos but scott snyder's
good at writing a particular kind of
story
the creepy batman but in terms of
writing batman as we imagine him right
like this
dark brooding character when you think
of like jason todd you know as like this
this hardcore vigilante
jeff johns knocks it out of the park
here right like he he he smashes it out
of the park because when batman breaks
into the ambulance right and confronts
the red hood the red hood and batman get
into like a little bit of a scuffle
right this leads to barbara gordon
basically using her uh using a kind of
drill of swords attached to the wheel
of her motorcycle and then taking out
the tires but then we switch over to
this truck right we switch over to the
ace chemical truck which is taken
and then driven into like this kind of
wooded area and then you end up having
of course like the joker getting out of
it the joker walking into a house or at
least walking up to a house he knocks on
the door and he's met by the killing
joke joker right so you got two jokers
here and so you kind of have them you
know going
going back and forth a little bit just
kind of being goofy telling jokes but
it's designed to showcase the nature of
their personalities
it's designed to show that like this
silver age joker was more cartoonish
right this guy was a little more silly
now the reality is that this version
of the joker was was in a lot of ways
the one that like steve
ingelhart's joker was based on it's the
one that batman the animated series
joker was based on he was a little more
sadistic than those versions but like he
it's it's kind of that version of the
joker in a lot of ways and then killing
joke joker is the one who's like dark
there's there's just there's something
about him it's just like
he's really really dark right like he's
hiding a monster inside right worse than
anything we've seen right it just looks
very sinister but of course they they
you know get inside the house and you
know basically killing joke joker tells
uh
you know killing joke joker tells a
silver age joker
wait until you see what the boss has
cooked up and that's what you end up
getting you kind of end up getting you
know these these two jokers talking to
the original joker this is the old
school
batman number one joker now look how old
he looks that's one of the first things
that hit me this guy looks old he's been
playing the part for a while
but basically he tells them like we're
gonna split into groups right like we're
gonna split up and we're all going to go
achieve a goal right where we're gonna
do something and so basically you end up
having batman and you have
jason todd and you have barbara gordon
who team up because each of them going
after a joker alone
is basically suicide because of how
dangerous the joker is the only real way
for them to seemingly pull this off is
to team up on one joker after another
right to you know all three of them hit
one joker all three of them hit another
and the three of them hit the last one
and that flies in the face of
conventional wisdom because historically
speaking they would have gone
gone through individually and then like
face off against different different
characters right so like something seems
a little amiss like something seems
you know a little a little strange but
it's the smartest move to make but
getting into the gotham city aquarium we
end up finding out that like this is
where the silver age joker's been
because what we end up getting here are
basically the joker fish right the
laughing fish the fish that have been
infected with the joker toxin
not only that and this is probably the
single creepiest thing that i think i've
ever seen in my life
a laughing shark this is horrifying and
even jason todd's like dude that's new
[Laughter]
that's new like that's a little bonkers
but of course then you end up having
like some silver age henchmen who
basically show up here you end up having
gaggy who was just kind of like
he was he was almost like joker's own
little robin to a degree it was kind of
weird and a little twisted but they
basically end up you know kind of going
in
and you know going after uh batman
because they've basically been tasked to
do so by the silver age joker now notice
as they get into this fight there's
gunshots being pulled
there's gunshots going and those
gunshots going are shooting into the
end of the tank they're literally
starting to crack the glass right and
what this does is it leads to jason todd
shooting the glass out of the tank the
shark comes flying out right it's just
like this
i mean shark's so roar but like you know
like it comes flying out and then like
eats gaggy
right and then the joker comes out of
nowhere and basically launches his
attack on like batman
and the bad family now the fact that the
joker comes running up on them with a
with a bowl like with a with a fishbowl
full of the laughing fish
this is silver aged joker this is the
kind of stuff he did right this is the
kind of comedic goofy nonsensical stuff
that the joker did back in the day like
that's just
the way he was during the silver age
he's immediately incapacitated by batman
and the bad family right now this right
here is our biggest clue that something
bigger is going on because of what sense
would it make to have the story how to
have like a three issue story about the
three jokers and like they're all taken
out in the first story what kind of
sense would that make right it'd be a
little weird
you have like commissioner gordon and
you have harvey bullock who chime in and
say like we got the other one and it
looks like the one that they took out
was the
uh was the killing joke joker although
we don't really see specifically
which one it is but it's like okay so
like he literally tells uh he tells
jason todd right he tells red hood and
he tells bad girl keep this guy roped up
you guys know how the joker is he's
always got something up his sleeve
like keep this guy away like like make
sure he's tied up make sure he doesn't
have a means of escape or anything like
that and it's one of these things where
you end up having red hood who like
pulls out one of the joker's playing
cards and the joker tries to spray him
with like his his acid lapel but then he
starts taunting jason and this is the
smartest thing this is this is what made
silver age joker so cool and so sadistic
if you go when you read like the old
like the old silver age comics of the
joker
if you go and you read this this version
of the joker that we saw that basically
existed between like the onset of the
silver age
and like the beginning of like the
crisis events right like like infinite
crisis final crisis right if you look at
this version of the joker
this is if you look past the the
silliness
if you look past the nonsense of it he's
wildly dangerous and he's incredibly
smart like if you if you look if you
look past all that stuff the way he's
written
he's amazing and he was really good at
getting in your head he was really good
at like getting getting in hero's heads
and screwing with him and that's what he
does with jason
right he's like it's kind of interesting
when jason goes to pull a gun and
barbara's like you know
like don't do this batman wouldn't do
this the responsive joker is i mean
you're right like batman wouldn't do
this but batman's not here is he
look at the facts let's look at what's
really going on like i
killed this guy i beat you with a
crowbar i blew you up and the mistake
you made jason was believing that you
mattered in all of it that's the mistake
you made you believe that i did that
because i was targeting you
i was never targeting you jason todd
you're collateral damage you were bait i
was targeting you
to target him i was hitting at you to
get to batman and then he starts kind of
making fun of him right he starts poking
at him and basically saying like you're
basically my robin now
that's really are you that's really what
you are i mean look at yourself you
exist in gotham you take people's lives
you make batman's life an absolute
living hell like you're
my you're my robin you're my henchman
you became
everything that i hoped you would you're
my henchman now you're me it's like dude
like i never looked at it that way
i never looked at it that way and it's
the crazy thing because he tells him
he's like do you remember what you said
when i was beating you with that crowbar
when i was killing you do you remember
what you said you said
please please why are you stop doing
this i'll tell you anything you want if
you stop and
it's kind of nuts because like when
we're getting that little bit of history
there
jason todd starts to cry right because
it's it's super personal
this is jason todd's version of like his
mom and dad being shot right the death
of jason todd at the hands of the joker
is far more potent because i mean if you
go and you look at like the or the
original origin original origin right
like when he first appeared in dc comics
his origin was the same
as dick grayson but that origin doesn't
really count anymore and so now it's
basically like jason todd was an orphan
you know somewhere along the line so
this is like a
super personal thing right he's being
made to relive the single biggest trauma
in his life and i love
love love the way this is being handled
right i absolutely
love the way that jeff jones is doing
this it makes red hood so personal if
i'm being honest with you guys i feel
like this personal touch of red hood has
been missing from dc comics for a long
time
it's one of the reasons why i stopped
reading the red hood comics right
because i feel like the like the the
actual
core who really is jason todd and let's
focus on that
has been gone for a while the stories
have been cool he's been shooting a lot
of stuff up but it's almost kind of been
like mindless action like mindless
violence you know as opposed to like
the character like focusing on the
nature of the red hood there's been a
few stories here and there that have
kind of shifted that up a bit but like
being written like this it's just it's
amazing to see and jason todd
has enough right like like literally red
hood has enough and so you have barbara
gordon watching jason todd and she's
like okay
literally his hand's shaking and it's
like he's literally falling in line with
like the killing joke joker's philosophy
right like all it takes is one bad day
and it's like he's he's sitting there
shaking and barbara gordon's like oh my
god he's gonna do it and like jason todd
doesn't want to but like he doesn't he
pulls the trigger
barbara gordon throws a batarang and
misses and jason todd
shoots the joker through the head like
he kills the joker who killed him and
it's just like
holy cow and barbara gordon's like what
did you do
what did you do and jason's like i ended
it right like i
finally ended this like i finally killed
the joker and barbara gordon
storms out right because she's like he's
like dude you wanted this as much as i
did and she's like no i didn't want any
of this and he said let me ask you
something barbara gordon when was the
last time you missed when you threw your
batarang and it seems to be that like
she did kind of want that like she did
sort of want the joker to die like on
some
super personal level that she's not
willing to admit to herself she wanted
that version of the joker to die
and so like she's like screw you like
she ultimately ends up storming off and
jason taj is sort of staring over this
body he simply says like i hope that's
the right one right like i really hope
this is the right joker the one who
killed me but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you